[Musica]
amici sportivi e non sportivi buongiorno
a tutti
[Applauso]
cos'è la rinascita nello sport e tornare
dopo una sconfitta soprattutto dopo una
brutta sconfitta racconto una sola cosa
qui 1986 87 prima del computer come
veniamo oggi primo del cellulare prima
di tutto che tempi antichi coppe dei
campioni e adesso si chiama eurolega col
pd campione di basket
la mia olimpio milano era dentro 24
squadre cosa facevano 12 accoppiamenti
primo turno di qualificazione dove si è
completamente andata ritorno che aveva
più portinaro vanta in rimanevano 12
squadre e dove ci andavano a casa
noi siamo passati abbiamo passato il
primo turno con mgm edimburgo scozia
permettetemi di dire una scuola della
scozia non può preoccupare la squadra di
basket in italia
ok quindi viali scozzesi sono contava
scozzese via gli scozzesi ok e abbiamo e
secondo torneo di qualificazione e non
sapevamo contro chi e qi comunicherò
aris salonicco grecia 86 ottobre la mia
squadra in pessime condizioni le
mericani arrivati in ritardo bob mark ii
che andarono una tragedia una fatica
enorme in campionato non abbiamo gambe
non abbiamo polmone è troppo presto per
noi loro grande squadra non sapevamo
niente mi è arrivato io con grande
presunzione mi arriva dalla fiba la
federazione internazionale
un fuori di carta a4 ok la lista dei
giocatori alla rosa non se non sapevo
neanche il nome del loro allenatore
adesso posso a johannes ioannidis si
chiama noi andiamo lì a salonicco
un un ambiente terrificante un lancio di
monete avesse potuto raccogliere tutto
sarei non sarei qui oggi a me sì ok
sputi non dico tutto che si diceva che a
salone che si vuole l'ombrello per gli
sputi un casco per le monete ok quindi e
ci hanno massacrato ci hanno steso
asfaltati 98 98 67 più 31 loro ero sotto
choc dice rinascite qua la prima di
rinascere tutte le mure io ero morto
la mia squadra era morta tutti tutti i
morti e io dicevo era un allenatore
fermata baby licenziano qua mi mandano a
casa cosa cosa potevo dire che abbiamo
vinto
no che abbiamo giocato bene no che
abbiamo la possibilità di passare il
turno
no avevamo sette giorni persone giovani
e salonicco vado in albergo cerca di
dormire dimenticare la parola dormire ok
se uno ti dice ieri notte non ho chiuso
occhio è una bugia a chiudere gli occhi
io non ho chiuso occhio torniamo a
milano
allenamenti e di gol non mi hanno
licenziato dopo la partita non dico non
lo fanno qui il corridoio furious poi mi
aspettano in albergo per licenziarmi non
mi hanno licenziato d'albergo
lo farò domani mattina all'aeroporto non
mi hanno licenziato tollo sono il coro
allenatore dell'olimpia milano
allenamento mio vice allenatore franco
casalini eco franco fai tu
venerdì ok io sotto choc non avendo
dormito che mi sono appoggiato mirci
dovranno però essere uscito da qua ma mi
sono appoggiato o sostegno del canestro
così per non cadere per terra tars
tarkas era uno zombie io franco fa tutto
l'allenamento di venerdì e fa cinque
minuti di verticale e dieci minuti di
stretching 15 tutte quelle cose lì ok
sabato mattina allenamento stesso
peterson appoggiato al sostegno casalini
battuto generalmente prima di ogni
allenamento salutavo tutti i giocatori
ci audino c'è ormai ciao luoghi non ho
parlato con nessuno
ero sotto shock uno zombie non ho
dormito nei giovedì nei venerdì nei
sabato domenica una partita ci onora
mente il ricordo tutto
non ricordo contro chi abbiamo giocato
so che abbiamo visto non ho parlato con
nessuno sono seduto in panchina fra che
ho fatto tutto abbiamo vinto loro di
martedì mercoledì allenamento peters
appoggiato non parla con nessuno
casalini fa tutto io non sto comunicano
con la squadra e non dormivo tutte le
note di queste tragedie o siamo la
squadra è costruito anno per anno
spogliatoio
giovedì cosa dici alla squadra parlando
della rinascita
non puoi drammatizzare tutto con numeri
e obiettivi
il real e allora generalmente prima
della partita io dicevo tre cose
intervallo due cose
time out una cosa una cosa se vuoi avere
successo
amici non parlare troppo poche parole ma
boni non fa il punto esclamativo sempre
fa il punto interrogativo fa le altre
parlare questa volta due sole cose nello
spogliatoio due sole cose ho detto la
squadra costa quasi parola per parola
ok detto voglio vincere questa partita a
milano anche per un solo punto ma se
vinciamo per un punto siamo fuori più 30
un loro più non lo è
del resto e 30 watt e ares o lenti
milano
ero sincero volevo vincere per noi per
watt e le squadre che ci ha messo fuori
dell'europa per i nostri tifosi
i nostri parenti amici figli in moglie
tutti quanti mass media e la stampa la
televisione gli sponsor dirigente tutto
il club
il nome tutti quello che interssata la
maglia dell'olimpia vinciamo per un
punto quando tu dici così tutto agli
stress perché questo vuol dire
pensiamo a vince la partita non 32 punti
di kobe che dovevamo recuperare
seconda cosa dico però se avete
intenzione non ho lavorato con numero
che non dico 32 non dico 31 se avete
intenzione di recuperare lo svantaggio
notare la scelta delle parole
ok è anche i numeri un consiglio non
aver fretta
adesso vado in numero buster ricuperare
un punto e di come sto facendo piccolo
piccolo piccole cose o che un punto ogni
minuto 40 minuti 40 punti passiamo turno
qualche caso intervallo avevamo
recuperato 14 punti non 16 che sarebbe
stata il numero giusto per arrivare a 32
ok non dico niente
ok poi è in campo fa riscaldamento non
guarda caso secondo tempo il tempo dura
venti minuti non c'erano qualche tempi
c'era un tempo dei venti minuti abbiamo
recuperato altri 20 punti un punto ogni
minuto totale 34
passiamo turno poi andiamo avanti il
grande slam vinciamo lo scudetto
italiano coppa italia e la coppa di
campione contro
maccabi tel aviv post scriptum a questo
io mi sono alzato dalla panchina dopo io
la pressione bassissima di sangue mio
medico dice peter un punto in meno
lei è addormentato ok e allora però lead
rally nava le mie gambe erano il cemento
puro ok ok e il lidl mi alzo così dalla
panchina
una volta diceva mi alzavo camminavo
come uno di 70 anni adesso che ne ho 83
non lo dico più ok e cerco di camminare
il capo resto sto parlando con le mie
gambe gambe andate andate no mi arriva
da indietro il mio grande americano bob
marche dei più grandi americano mai
venuto in europa e mi vedeva un sub
lussazione della spalla destra e dice
coach l'abbiamo fatto allora la disse in
inglese
then we didn't che spiego io faccio
luoghi ancora io che lo so è un miracolo
e lui si arrabbia con me e disse
miracolo cosa stai dicendo
eravamo convinti tutti io non ero
convinto per nulla
ok e dico voi eravate tutti convinti
come mai è lui dice abbiamo visto nostro
allenatore così tranquillo tutta la
settimana
[Applauso]
e noi siamo rinati amici sportivi non
sportivi alla biogas
[Applauso]